m
dans le cadre des nuits sans lumière une
classe de segpa du collège de canon a
mis en place un projet en partenariat
avec le parc national de la réunion
une sensibilisation à la protection des
pétrels en adéquation avec le programme
scientifique des élèves se sont engagés
dans ce projet sur l'eau temps libre
dont il avait une heure de deux libres
dans leur emploi du temps ils sont venus
depuis red hat rina cela donc pour
préparer le projet avec stc en début
d'année ils sont partis
ton fougères donc avec le parc national
des hauts pour donc en forêt donc ils
ont là ils ont découvrir des espèces
endémiques
ce soir la fois que ce soit à la flore
et depuis ils ont travaillé autour de ce
projet permettrait donc et dont la
finalité un peu aujourd'hui c'est
présenté des affiches ils sont
aujourd'hui ambassadeur et il finit en
finaliseront donc ce projet donc ce
lundi
ils iront donc à saint-andré pour le
lâcher pétrels et visiter la sellor la
semaine prochaine le parc national est
intervenu directement dans
l'établissement afin d'expliquer aux
jeunes les menaces qui pèsent sur les
pétrels et qu'ils puissent comprendre
les enjeux à la sauvegarde de cette
espèce alors dans le cadre des nuits
sans lumière donc trois semaines en
avril
justement je suis venu aujourd'hui au
collège de canon donc pour faire une
sensibilisation l'éducation
l'environnement donc sur les menaces qui
pèsent sur le pétrel de barau donc sous
forme de conte donc un compte en créole
qui s'intitule l'oiseau la mer dont qui
racontent aux fêtes tous les péripéties
que le pétrole doit traverser aura
rejoindre l'océan est aussi on a diffusé
un film documentaire de cinq minutes de
cinq minutes
donc ils m'ont fait
le pétrel de barau sur les colonies
enfin sur son site de nidification et
les menaces qui pèsent sur l'espace des
élèves tous très investie dans ce projet
ils sont aujourd'hui fiers de pouvoir
partager leurs connaissances sur la
petite chose d'intéressant
j'ai bien appris des choses avec toi
gt300 causant la réunion sky race pitres
et rats se répétera de barbe relations
similaires
et le pk201 de bobo il reste 10 à 15
coups en fait pour retravailler avec été
très bien je trouvais que c'est très
intéressant pour protéger les pétrels
parce qu'en fait main les pétrels je
crois qu'elles ont besoin d'être que
pour s'envoler pour était la lumière
parce qu'on peut les protéger
moi j'aimais bien ses projets pour
finaliser leur travail les élèves
participeront à un lâcher de pétrel au
parc du colosse
les nuits sans lumière se poursuivront
jusqu'au 24 avril prochain